as you can see oh yeah diving right into
it
I mean DJing on the side recently DJ
yeah and it's been going great DJ cops
getting a lot of gigs here in Jersey and
New York and I could see myself getting
famous eventually right too I could see
it dude to be like [__]
I'd like to ask you a few questions
where were you July 21st
freeze drugs you you doing drugs
I'll let it slide because it's pretty
lit
wrong
[Music]
happy July 16th How We Living G I'm
living good G cool uh uh so anyway I'll
be in Vegas next week and I'll also be
in Charlotte and Knoxville and Little
Rock Arkansas coming up here so go to
chrisley.com to get tickets patreon.com
Lifeline luxury a new episode of
Lifeline luxury is out today you get
that only on our patreon
um so uh that's you really want to sign
up for that let me tell you something
that's uh that's the best podcast I
think I might like it even better than
this one if I'm being honest yeah it's
it yeah it's uh right now it comes and
goes yeah right now I'm feeling luxury
I'm gonna tell you something they're
both very good yeah they're both they're
both very good top two pockets in the
world so
um yeah I've got a question for uh for
us go to watch lifeline.com that's for
this show Lifeline or just click in the
link in description below baby yep or
leave a message on the hotline at
213-973-8095 if you want one-on-one
advice with me
go to matilia.com and book book it how
about saving people's lives recently
over there how about the one how about
the merch though too lifelinemerch.com
you can get all this stuff right here we
show it on the thing uh but it's really
great uh you get the purple purple and
all that stuff yeah stutter
dude how you feeling man you know what
uh it's I'm just so happy that it's now
really really beautiful and nice out and
it wasn't for a long time there
beautiful nice it's hot as hell that's
what I mean beautiful and nice no dude
it's not nice nope love it too hot love
it I'm tan but here's the thing you
don't really sweat I sweat a lot I swear
when I work out
Oh you mean like everyone in the world
no but I go harder Oh you mean like
everyone in the entire world okay that's
not true dude when I go to the gym I
look around I'm like why are these
people not sweating some people do and
me I'm one of them okay and drip
physical exercise
sweat I I sweat I'm just sitting there
you know what I'm saying yeah but I like
how I make money I make money like I
sweat just sitting there oh wow okay
well what I like is being outside and
being warm and feeling the warmth and I
do that all the time and I am now I have
a slight tan and that's what's up for
the summer and whoopsy Daisy but have a
slight tan and um you don't really get
very tan no I know but I have uh I get
10 walking the dog I get I get 10 check
in the mail
I get dark dude I'm in the Sun for 10
minutes I get dark no that's I mean not
10 minutes 10 minutes really yeah dude
yeah
and then if I'm in there for like an
hour I'm all of I'm just like I look
like I'm straight off the boat from
Italy you know what I'm saying uh what
this is going on I was out in the sun
for one hour yeah I want to be like that
yeah well too bad but it's okay dude
um I've been in the pool with Calvin
I've been outside I've been hiking I've
been doing all sorts of crazy [__] so
and if a blister on my foot yes dude
kiss up think about it hurts so bad
that's cool does William go in the pool
William that has gone to the pool yeah
but not not actually in the pool but on
a floaty in the pool yeah
not like underwater and stuff does he
have like a Vibe yet or is he's just too
young he's very yeah he he's pretty
young but he has a Vibe where he's just
smiling all he's a very Smiley oh really
yeah that's really Smiley Calvin was
more like this
and Williams just Smiley dude because I
wasn't a smiley well he was a happy baby
in the sense that I remember him being
so happy no no well he never cried right
that's right but William is like
even when he's crying just yeah that's
specifically when he's crying
um so that's that's that but yeah it's
um it's really it's cool William is
finally becoming uh like um
I'm starting to feel like a real
connection with them because he's like
looking at me and like you know yes
because it it takes I was like you know
I mean look you feel like some sort of
connection with the with the baby
because it's yours however the Mom feels
a connection because
it's inside her she's been housing it
she's been housing she's been housing it
right I've been housing and so when they
come out it's like oh this is what I've
been housing yeah and they already have
that relationship in houses to German
you when the baby's born you just look
at it and you're like what are you
you're a blob of skin and bones yeah and
it's literally just a blob and chilling
and it doesn't look at you and it just
makes kind of some noises and it shits
yeah and so you're like okay what do I
do here and then finally when it starts
to make eye contact with you and then
when it starts to like grab something
then you're like all right okay
connection connect gang bing bing bang
bang you know what I mean like like
dubsy said that's yeah
wow that's so dorky that they did that
actually connecting connecting bing bing
bang I mean that's like the Donald Trump
thing you know
Donald Trump stole that for me I'm gonna
sue him no Donald Trump stole it from uh
Mac 10 and Ice Cube and dubsy right okay
no I stole it from Mac 10. okay from me
oh he doesn't listen to rap
Trump doesn't no well he doesn't used to
listen to my podcast though but he
always talks about how he likes rappers
because rappers love Trump he does talk
about that like Lil Wayne takes pictures
yeah yeah I'm sure he did right Connie I
don't really think of him as a rapper
but yeah I mean he is a rapper for sure
but I think of him more as like a a
person crazy person
you know right my contacts are blurry
today
so what we do when that happens is we
get new ones no but put new ones in your
eyes
sometimes they adjust though you've worn
context before right yeah I mean I used
to you don't ever did no no that's cool
I was like why don't you get Lasik don't
want to get off my back so get off my
back okay but let's talk about off of it
a wrestler a wrestler that just quit so
you have
um glasses you don't find it annoying to
have those on your face I love wearing
glasses why it's like part because it's
the same it's like
look it's not like this but it's as much
of a part of like my day or my routine
whatever you want to call it as coffee
what I I feel now when I wear contacts
I'm like what
where's everything so okay so why is it
like coffee though because I feel like I
don't wake up until I go through the
routine and one of the routines is like
wow I need to have more routines so the
glasses stay I'm not getting Lasik okay
for anybody unless if the apocalypse
seems like it's really right around the
corner I'm getting them because I don't
want to need glasses when the apocalypse
comes you can't need stuff like that or
you need to keep that to a minute so how
early does the apocalypse have to seem
like it's coming before you can listen
because that shit's gonna get booked up
so yeah you're right but so when like
the first
10 politicians are killed
that's already seems like it's coming
with it exactly yeah so so you had to do
it before that you have to oh yeah
before that but yeah by yeah oh no I was
saying the tenth one I gotta I I'm going
the tenth one I'm getting booked for
Lasik dude the tenth one because then
it's already gone to [__] yeah Lacey's
gonna be so booked up by the time five
politics I guess you get killed okay
okay so we
um
okay what if no politicians get killed
but there's like tsunamis and there's
like volcano volcanic eruptions how many
of those none that natural disaster
isn't what I'm talking about oh my god
like people burning it all down and like
why don't natural guns in the streets
and people like taking over guns and
streets is kind of in a way
a natural disaster in a way now at this
point well that would be an unnatural
design I know I know it's unnatural but
I'm saying the way it happens it would
make the same waves as a natural
disaster people would just be massively
dying okay but it's not to me it's not
the same thing okay so only getting I'm
only getting LASIK if it's people in the
streets with guns and like
militias taking over town and stuff okay
so what about this no guns in the
streets
no volcanic eruptions no earthquakes
three politicians get assassinated
you're getting Lasik I'm gonna book it
in six months and then if I if another
one gets hit if I change my mind if it
all evens out everything's fine then I'm
you know what I don't even show up so
yeah so doc so it turns out there wasn't
a fourth politician that really got shot
and uh there's no guns on the street so
I'm not gonna get Lasik yeah yeah all
right so no earthquakes no no tsunamis
are gonna make I got like six pairs of
glasses I'll just grab a few and I'm
good you know what I'm saying so what is
it about the people because then like
they want your businesses closed down
you got to stay home businesses close
down if there's a [__] this is crazy
but if there's a tsunami it's already
too late you know it's like I'm already
screwed if I don't know the Lasik you
know we should get Lasik dude maybe but
here's the thing get in one eye here's
the thing yeah test it out get it one
night so you still wear glasses it's
nice you have one prescription but if
the [__] hits a van Gogh I got it
covered yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah uh
no but it's also like 99 9.8 percent I'm
not gonna mess with my eyes it has to be
a hundred every single time it has to
work perfectly for me to do it 99.8 what
success for that Lasik yeah and and then
the other point two percent it's it's
not like you go blind no it doesn't work
no it's not but I I've like there's
there's a famous baseball player who had
the Lasik he's a catcher and scoot up
his eyes
for like
two years two whole years and then what
he couldn't play baseball for two years
and then what happened after he came
back after that how good was he not as
good because he's older and wasn't how
did it get fixed it's just like time I
think I don't even think maybe he had
another surgery I'll get some more of
that stories don't be a [__] catcher
right yeah you better you shouldn't be a
catcher if you're gonna yeah live all
right well
um all right that's interesting I didn't
know that you love wearing glasses I do
I feel like it's a part of me when I
wear my glasses I feel dirty
you know why yep I do know why okay cool
you want to tell everybody yeah just
because when I wake up in the morning or
when I'm going to sleep and that's the
only time is before I take a shower
actually yeah yeah yeah totally for you
it's like the opposite for you basically
as it is yeah yeah for sure yeah so if
you wore glasses if you didn't wear
glasses and you had contacts in during
the day you feel like weird all day you
think I've worn contacts enough recently
oh you have this is weird yeah when I
mean when I was in that movie I was in
recently uh oh I didn't uh oh you had to
wear contacts yeah
oh yeah and you felt bad and every once
in a while I'll wear them if I if I
don't wanna like what
like sometimes if I go to a movie I will
really yeah just watch the movie and
then I'll throw them away because it's a
little sharper like wow what a cinephile
dude yeah gotta keep it sharp dude I'm
gonna send a file too no you're not nice
yeah I am you know why no no why because
I saw the movie hypnotic with Ben
Affleck oh wow that movie looks so bad
dude don't
it is topple you over do a somersault
it is
dude
it's one of those movies where
it's so bad but before that you think
I actually this script yeah is dog [__]
the idea is dog [__] so let's think
about why it exists
Ben Affleck I guess but here's the thing
what's up with Ben Affleck Ben Affleck
could be
and arguably he has been this at various
points throughout his career he could be
the biggest star in the world yeah and
his choices make it seem like he's
desperate for work I know and he's
always been the case for him though as
an actor why would he do a movie
hypnotic even the accountant was a weird
Choice like what do you know it was so
weird I think he thought that was gonna
be like John Wick
but that wasn't but hypnotic I don't
understand the thought behind it what is
uh hypnotic about yeah dude it's about a
God the only way I can explain it is
William fickners in it right yeah yeah
he plays a guy who can not hypnotize
people it's hypnotics it's a different
thing that you can learn how to do and
you can just basically get so good at it
that it's basically you're a Jedi you're
like take a seat and the person will
have to sit down right and
it's already a bad idea right it's
already a bad idea okay so so but
there's a faction like there's a whole
faction that learns how to do this and
there's a few people in the world that
can do it and
they do things like rob banks right
right in the trailer and and Ben Affleck
is the guy to uncover all this
because
it doesn't work on him
right he's like immune to it right
is he a cop or something what is it you
know why he's immune to it the reason
why he's immune to it is because
he spoiler alert used to be in the
faction of course but doesn't remember
because
he did it himself wiped his own memory
cool cool I love this movie by just
going like this
is it non-visual like that no I mean
they don't show him wipe his memory
right but I'm saying when they do it is
it just oh dude it's
are they physically is anything
happening visually when they do it no
when they make people do stuff no
you're just looking at a guy standing
there and it's the kind of thing where
it's like you can make people think
you're someone else yeah like I'm not me
I'm actually
I'm Anthony now and you're looking at me
and then I go like this second Chris all
the time and then it cuts to you and
cuts me in now now I'm Chris you see
what the actor dude it's so
unbelievably bad who what it I I I I I I
if you look up who made that movie who
wrote it he directed it it is uh it was
Rodriguez
oh Robert Rodriguez I knew that that's
right that's why Ben Affleck did it
right of course there's no other reason
yes wow Robert Rodriguez he's done some
good stuff Robert Rodriguez has sucked
at making movies since before he started
making movies he's never made something
that I think is cool oh really yeah
Desperado was cool when I was a kid but
I was a kid yeah yeah it's not cool do
the thing with the gun in the there's
also No Frills and [__] and like
the gun in the guitar case and he bends
down on his legs
that's actually [__] stupid yeah you
guys don't like Desperado there we go
no I I I I I have to see it again so who
wrote it who wrote it
um oh he wrote it wow dude just get go
away you know what it is it's such a
film no he should keep doing it if he's
making money for it but he it's such a
film that would be the idea would be
somebody in film school had it yeah yeah
yeah first year yeah yeah and uh second
year you realize that's trash but so
anyway
um I I I it isn't it is in it is in for
sure my top 10 worst movies of all time
but it is it may be in my top five I'm
not sure and that is with the new Matrix
top five and one woman 1984.
wow I haven't seen anyone uh either one
of those movies so I can't order this
one for that matter yeah people like to
forget that Pedro Pascal was in 1984
Wonder Woman 194 he wasn't so good and
that was he dude that movie [__]
sucked donkey balls he might have been
good but the movie was bad anyway all
right well let's get to a caller right
this is Lifeline luxury we talk about
[__] like this it's fun but uh this
is you said that wrong this is not
Lifeline luxury but what we just did is
what Lifeline luxury is like
let's do it
Matt and Chris what the [__] is up guys
so aggressive this is disclaimed real
quick I know it's dark [__] right now
um and we're gonna be in a shift as a
cop as you can see oh yeah
um and I don't want to stick out like a
sore thumb with the [__] interior
lights on sure sure anyways diving right
into it it's just a robbery I mean on
the side recently DJ yeah and it's been
going great DJ cops getting a lot of
gigs here in Jersey and New York officer
connections off the [__] Wazoo
and I could see myself getting famous
eventually me too I could see it and you
know with the connections I've made and
the potential of that happening is like
pretty high but hell yeah dude this guy
cocky [__] I know [__] it but I don't
see myself going through that process
unless I'm like fully immersed today
yeah yeah yeah
um and as you can see I have a safety
net job which takes up half my [__]
half the year I'm working doing this
Duty and [__] so my question is
you know
fueling your passion going all the way
into something that you know interesting
and you you wouldn't see yourself
struggling with
um doing for the rest of your life
is it worth going through all that like
taking the pay cut like saying [__] it
to like your safety net you know
potentially disappointing a lot of
people
to to go all in on this yeah
let me know what you guys think dude I
mean you can't do both you know that's
insane that's like that is would be a
script as bad as hypnotic dude to be
like [__]
let it slide because it's pretty lit
uh I think that I need backup guard the
ones and twos
this is crazy yeah that is actually
crazy I don't even know like in general
I know what the kind of advice to give
it it's like do I follow my passion or
keep my safety net this is
really weird yeah specific I don't think
being a cop pays anything so yeah to
consider it like a really solid enough
yeah well no that's not true no it does
it does but it you you that's not true
at all you you're you're always gonna
Wonder
if you are keep being a police officer
you're always going to wonder if you
should have
gone into the [__] DJ I mean can't
you go back to being a cop though like
police forces yeah so bad these days
like they're they're you can go be a cop
even if it's not at the same station
that you're a Precinct that you're in
right now you if you took like five
years off you could absolutely go and be
a complicated yeah probably yeah so do
that 100 do that that's a good idea I've
already been through all the training
you could find it dude actually you know
what that happens all the time cops get
hired in just different precincts
different states different counties
whatever like you can do that have a
future as a cop if you want DJ and a cop
do DJ freeze
oh DJ Fresh pretty good yeah
DJ hands up
swallowing swallowing [__]
oh man
um
gotta leave the bag behind I don't know
yeah it's just so it's so
I get it dude the music is inside you
bro God I can't imagine being an idiot
could you imagine being an idiot what
will be worse being a DJ cop I guess a
cop because you worry about you're gonna
get [__] I would rather be a cop you
can get your wig split
though I'd see all the corruption and be
like no
and I would go to simplifying go to the
D.A and it'd be like these guys are bad
so simplifying it no dude I would become
a cop see all the corruption on me and
when they would come to me and say you
got to be corrupt too I would say no and
then I would go straight to the DA's
office and I would say they're bad so
like newspapers
in one minute long
no dude hey that bad
he's not old in that dude come on he
doesn't sound like that uh
[Music]
he that movie's great how did he have a
voice like this and then a turn to this
I mean that makes sense I can't wait
does it's kind of it's completely
different nice to meet you dude it's
completely different yeah dude that's
great uh you did that too hard it's all
good oh I don't know my own story no I'm
a rock climber now so nah wait I did
deadlifts that's what it has the same
voice it's just a different like isn't
it isn't the same it's just like this
and then oh it's the same thing yeah
it lost your mind
oh
but how did it go from I can't wait to
see what my voice is like dude my voice
can be so dope when I'm 90.
what did you say I can't yeah I'm
[__] 90.
that's what you're doing
what's going on watch where you go I
[__] help me out here I [__] I
want to take a walk to the [__]
kitchen island eh well get some cheese
one in it
um yeah dude that's yeah be a DJ Hiatus
from being a try to be a DJ DJ [__]
spin those rounds baby imagine a DJ
freezer how you getting anybody like you
used to be a cop that's hilarious dude
dude this is a Don Johnson movie that
came out in [__] 1991 yes yep first
his first movie that was like [__]
trying to make him a movie star from
from uh
um yeah all right dude just be a cop
later yeah be a cop later okay
Vin Diesel hey what's up boys uh big fan
I love both you guys
um but I just wanted some quick advice
on cutting back on caffeine because I
know Chris talked about uh quitting like
coffee and stuff the whole time he was
in rehab and I am trying to get on that
level of cutting back on caffeine so
just didn't know if you went cold turkey
or how you did it any advice from either
you guys would be appreciated I'll tell
you right now
um first of all that
when's last time you having drink coffee
isn't that good
oh when's last time you
um like what do you mean I haven't had a
coffee in a day yeah
I don't know a long time okay so uh
if you don't drink it you'll get
headaches right yes so that doesn't
really matter you could just take
Excedrin or whatever some people shake
more no no but I'm saying the headaches
don't matter right I'm saying on top of
the headaches some people should what
we're doing is we're singularly talking
about the headaches at this point
um so
so the headaches I'm saying are not that
big of a deal okay people talk about the
headaches I got the headaches when I was
in rehab I didn't do the coffee and I
would get the headaches the headaches
lasted was that part of rehab yeah they
don't let you drink caffeine why they
don't want you under any influence of
anything but yum yum give me some you
can't smoke cigarettes give me some but
no these cigarettes no way
you know what I'm saying that's what I
would be like at rehab you know what I'm
saying but they don't let you no some
rehabs do but not they've got to go to
that one well you messed up that's what
yeah you messed up the reason why they
don't want you to do anything like that
is because they don't they want to see
what your base level is okay so
they want you to feel actually how
you're feeling and that is sure yeah
pretty yeah yeah yeah uh standard for uh
sex addiction rehab if you're doing drug
rehab it might be a different story
right right okay right yeah yeah
um because you don't have to feel your
feelings necessarily I mean I still
think you do but it's about getting off
of that right like I know sober people
who smoke yeah of course right yeah yeah
right and they're not like breaking um
you know yes uh that doesn't mean that
after you do they don't say don't smoke
after you do it they just want to figure
out like like I wasn't able to take any
any of um
no you can't take that you can if it's a
certain type of drugs you can take got
it uh but but not if it's something you
can be dependent on right right I I I've
taken [__] Xanax nine times in my
life but
um
anyway uh so it wasn't a big deal but
the caffeine gave me headaches I did not
have shakes and I drink a lot of
caffeine so I all of a sudden stopped I
would get headaches I take the Excedrin
and it was fine however I did notice
um I wanted to drink coffee so I was I
guess addicted to it however
I will tell you right now that if you
want to get off of coffee completely
that's one thing if you want to drink
less it's easier to do you can just uh
reply this sounds like I I talk about
this but like if you if you straight up
there are days where I drink one coffee
and just drink magic mind and it is like
I drank coffee all day it keeps you
alert but not buzzed and it is like you
drank caffeine but you don't feel buzzed
and it actually helps for that I don't
know if it's gonna help with the
headaches but Excedrin does so if you
really want to get off caffeine
um try magic mind genuinely that that
works amazing so uh and you'll end up
spending less money on it too but you
know and I am I I am not employed by
Magic mind I do not they do not pay me
it's just a great [__] product uh
yeah I was gonna say come with a
replacement of which there are many now
there are that is one but there's like
mushroom coffee I have a friend that's
like right he was diagnosed with some
he's fine but he's diagnosed with some
weird thing with I think liver maybe but
like coffee was one of the things that
was upsetting his stomach and he's on
he's got like mushroom and turmeric
called it's like so many things like
that I'm sure it's terrible yeah yeah I
was like is it good he's like no but
like sometimes coffee isn't good you
just yeah it's a habit true especially
if you get from Alfred's I don't even
think it's the caffeine you know it's
just like oops it's not bad though it's
really good the vanilla latte at at
Alfred well I don't get a vanilla latte
because I'm not buying coffee for my
wife the vanilla latte which is the
world famous vanilla latte okay of
Alfred everything's world famous dude no
that's the only thing no in the world
they just put it on a sign that's the
only thing in the world that's world
famous uh no it's the only on the menu
that says world famous because they put
it on a sign well it tastes so good it
might as well be world famous okay yeah
just got fire
just go far away
so just confirming dinner tonight yes
dude I have his [__] life Wow Wow all
right do you go to dinners and [__] go
to dinners like what like do you have a
do you have like a friend that's like yo
let's let's go [__] Thursday a friend
man you really don't pick out single
words I'm saying just listen to the
whole thing okay I'll try dinners a
friend
no I meant like dinners like dinner
parties or just going no like do you
have a friend that's like let's get
dinner Thursday and then you say okay
yeah I usually end up before Thursday
though after I say okay saying I'm not
gonna yeah
I'm going tonight I made a plan last
week and I'm gonna make myself do things
like that more now than I used to
I make myself because I've found that
yeah even if I don't enjoy the
experience being social is good for me
it is just like
a vitamin is good it's like it's it's
like we're social animals and that
actually I think means something like we
need to be around people to actually
have any kind of semblance of Happiness
yeah and so even if I'm like oh I don't
really like those people and yeah I said
yes I don't want to go but I'll make
myself go more often than not now and
yeah even on the way home I'll be like
man that sucks but I'm happy I did that
really yeah yeah it's like working out
yeah well you know what is interesting
every single thing that is discussed
with you you will talk end up talking
about working out by the end of the
discussion I mean it's not interesting
Now isn't that interesting it is
interesting dude I do I did squats
yesterday
so that's crazy and that's all I did
that's all I did it was a light workout
for me I did heavy stuff but it was a
light workout for me it wasn't as long
as I usually go it was 50 minutes I know
I don't want you to keep going but this
time I don't today I'm gonna do
deadlifts after my school I want you to
keep going okay okay
all right next one
then someone squats amen Chris I had a
little question for you so I'm a single
dad I have two little boys four and six
I'll see five and seven you don't care
anyway
in this weighs about a year and a half
now and they've been that age for that
they lack a mother figure in their life
that's right because they don't see
their long story it's like the reverse
deadbeat situation right but should I be
looking for a stepmother figure for them
or should I just keep my nose down and
keep grinding like I am right because
we're in a world where you can't really
live off one income right so you do you
take the selfish route and
go look for you know relationships
outside of your kids yeah or do you just
be a slave your whole life well until
they're adults and then go find
partner
because I get this guilt feeling anytime
I even start talking to a female because
it's going to take that minuscule amount
of time that oh you know it could be
spent with the kids oh so I don't know
however thinking things should I just be
single dad work my ass off reward myself
later in life or should I be trying to
find someone now I don't know
thanks love the podcast guys you get me
through a lot of hard times have a good
one thanks for listening
that's a really great uh question that's
a great question and I
believe I at least have an answer which
is the answer I don't think that not I
don't think that staying single and
focusing solely on your kids is uh
necessary in any way I don't think that
that will make your kids lives better
even I agree I don't think that I think
that is a misplaced uh
it's like you're being a good person
it's like misplaced morality or
something you know like but that's not
actually going to make your children's
lives better right it's going to make
you less guilty possibly yeah but but I
would say absolutely at least try but
you don't have to like try to the point
that you're going to make something work
even if it doesn't work but you you owe
it to yourself you open the love to be
happy yeah and your kids
here's the deal your kids whether they
act like it or not at five and seven
ultimately will be happy if you are
happy the more happy you are the more
likely your kids will have a chance to
be happy in their own lives so think
about that think about how much more joy
you could have
if you found the right partner for you
your kids would see that they would
learn what a healthy relationship looks
like a number of things are good about
that if you're worried about your kids
I'd say again Don't Force It Don't just
date someone because you feel like you
have to but that's a good thing for
children to see model a good
relationship for them yeah and you don't
need to look for a mom you need to look
for love and somebody that you'll be
happy with that will and you know effect
be a good person to be in their lives as
well uh yeah I I don't I don't the guilt
thing it bothers me because it's not
you're not you don't need to that's all
you bro that's all you yeah I mean of
course it's time taking away
from you being with them I guess but
that's not a bad thing like they can't
be with that 100 yeah they need to learn
how to be functional without you and
it's it's it's okay the guilt thing is
not something that's all that's all
constructed in your head and you know
yeah for sure I mean dude I feel guilty
[__] coming here I want to go to I
want to be with the kids but you know
you should do that more let me run it no
but also I gotta work out but that's
good for them you know they want me to
be [__] strong with deadlifts so dumb
okay
um yeah you're a good dude you owe it to
yourself to be as happy as you can
possibly be plus it sounds like your
relationship with their mother is rough
and that's always so weird when a mom
isn't in the kids lives I mean it's also
a weird one that isn't though
it's so weird when a parent has a child
and they're like nah it's less weird
with it with the dad why is it less
weird
because it's inside it's more common
obviously
but it's also less weird because
you a guy can literally splurt and then
never see the woman again yeah women and
so they'll never see the baby don't ever
think think about the baby don't ever
think about the woman but that's not
deadbeat a deadbeat no no no they know
that they have the kids I understand
yeah don't show up for it well except
for is it deadbeat if you meet somebody
have one night with them then you go
somewhere else where you live and they
where they they're where they live they
have a kid they decide to keep it and
you say well I don't want to be a dad
that's not necessarily deadbeat that's
just oh I didn't want to it is if you
don't help financially support the child
well that's all that deadbeat means oh
Debbie means a financing well you're not
present and you don't Finance you don't
help financially
it's like I think you know it's actually
illegal right it's like laws yeah yeah
yeah I get that you know like you can't
really have a kid if you're not prepared
to work for it to make money for it to
live otherwise it's like it's an
Enterprise that is beneficial to nobody
who's creating more people who don't
have food to eat you know
um
but yeah
given your situation dude just try to
again don't like hurry into anything
just for the sake of it but try to meet
somebody
you know maybe you'll be horizontaling
before you know it meet somebody and
meet somebody wow
all right yeah good luck dude yeah good
luck man sounds like you're a good guy I
have shorts on it looks like I have no
pants I'm gonna have shorts on nice
uh Hey man hey man uh I have a quick
question
um I proposed to my boyfriend because he
always said that he wanted me to propose
before he proposes to me so I did that
yay
um but I guess the timing wasn't great
because I thought it would be funny but
you know we went to Disneyland and then
we got a turkey leg and then when we got
home we both had
um
explosive diarrhea and I thought it'd be
so funny if I proposed to him after that
because you know if you can get through
that together enough to your bathroom
with that then you know you can get
through anything but I guess he was
really mad about it because he was not
having a good time so he wants me to
redo it which is fair
um but I was hoping that you could tell
me how should I do it because I'm not a
very romantic person uh and he wants
something a little more romantic so any
help would be great thanks
the guy is the most gigantic [__] in
the world that's what's going on here he
Not only was like I don't want to ask
you to marry me I want you to ask me
fine I guess fine whatever teach their
own who cares right yeah I did it
the way that she so chose which
obviously she thought was a good way to
do it even though it was you know amid a
horrible diarrhea session which you know
to each their own
um but he was mad that she did it then
because he wasn't feeling well so now
he's insisting she has to ask him again
at another time in another setting that
is like more something he would like
here's the deal here why don't you do it
if you want if
because the Gen the typical gender
situation here is reversed yeah I think
it's easy to miss something here and
it's that
that guy is in a like the biggest
[__] [__] I can even imagine and
it's being just it's being like a
blurred by the fact that like it's it's
like the woman asking the man yeah I
think you're missing something here nice
woman who has called in and asked the
question and it's that you're
soon to be husband
sucks dude well that guy sucks is it a
joke
no like why she would have said so let
me ask a question if you're a guy that
wants the woman to propose to you that's
one thing right but but what I don't get
and what throws me all off is
he's saying not just that I want you to
propose to me before I propose to you
that's what I don't get so if he's going
to do it anyway you're getting hung up
on the wrong how am I getting on the
wrong things that that was just her way
of saying it she doesn't mean there's a
time when he's going to ask and she
better do it before he I know that I
know that he just wants her to ask him
no so then why are you bringing up the
other thing that doesn't matter because
she's oh she's saying yes
you better do it before I do it so I
don't have to do it
all he's saying is you have to do it but
then that's what he's saying that yes it
is he said you have to propose to me
before I propose to you right but all
that means that you're getting hung up
on like just am I or is that what it
raised that doesn't mean anything though
how could you consider that that's
something to mean that you can't you
can't mean that because it makes no
sense so he's not gonna be like thanks
for proposing to me yes now in his head
okay I gotta propose to her no he's not
doing that no because no one's ever done
that
is that obvious
yes
boss really yeah am I dude I honestly
think I have Asperger's yeah you'd
probably I'm not even trying to make fun
of people with Aspirin no I know you're
saying you have it [__] you have
something you fixate I didn't understand
that because of that and I fixed it you
fix it that's not necessary guys two
things was I wrong in the comments yes
or did you think the way I thought and
do you think I have Asperger's for real
only people with Asperger's are gonna be
like yeah you thought the right thing
um
uh okay oh wow I was completely off
there no but all it is is that he wants
her to ask she did and he's like no
that's not good enough do it again I
mean okay I I understand that's [__]
except for it was during explosive
diarrhea but it was funny and she said
so it was like I I think she's right
that is kind of funny like if the guy
did it to the girl after explosive
diarrhea she would make him redo it
but that didn't happen so what does that
have to do it didn't happen because what
because the girl did the guy but you
can't come up with a counter factual
that didn't happen and be like if that
happened you're saying it would be the
same way so then if the roles were
reversed but how do you even know that
it didn't happen that way how can you
make that claim you can't make it
generally if you ask a woman to marry
you after explosive diarrhea they're
gonna wish you did it differently and
did it again
no I don't I don't know of that as like
a common thing when people are like no
that's the wrong way to ask do it again
I know I've never even heard of that
explosive diarrhea thing that she's
doing it listen because she thinks it's
funny to do it then and this should be a
very touching moment a non-explosive
diarrhea moment it says there's a reason
why the [__] commercial isn't every
kiss begins with
it's because it's not it's not beautiful
you want that moment to be beautiful but
to her it was
and and he's making her do it in the
first place
he's making her do it
she doesn't know how or want to she did
the best she could then he said no do it
again a different way come on do the
best she could did she do the best she
could she because she had set up a
picnic she thinks so could she have set
up a picnic after all of her bowels were
evacuated made a nice sandwich and put
some [__] candles up and said will
you marry me [__] by the way because you
do it well that's that's my thing if you
don't if there's a possibility that you
won't like the way someone does it do it
yourself whether you're a man or a woman
you [__] [__] you can't be like
you got to do the thing that is is
really important and okay you got to do
it your way I'm just gonna wait and
you're gonna surprise me whenever it
happens then when that happens you're
like no no that wasn't right you got to
do it again later whether you're a man
or a woman you're a [__] [__] if
you do that I don't care that's so
[__] shitty and stupid dude come on I
don't know I I you decided with that guy
I don't side with that guy I don't I do
not side with that guy I think think
that
I I think that it's he the guy's being a
baby I do think the guy's being a baby
but I think I unders if it wasn't
explosive diarrhea bro
if it wasn't during so explosive
diarrhea bro you're asking someone to
marry you you're not [__] signing a
lease on a car all right let me ask you
something
this happens to you and Kristen yeah
before you're married or even engaged
yeah after it happens you guys are like
obviously you're either you're laughing
or you're like commiserating yeah and
then she says she proposes to you I
don't give a [__] I think it was cute
but that's because I I may
she knows this guy this guy's his own
she thought it would be funny and cute
which is what she said I agree I would I
would do the same thing I would say yes
and think it was funny I'll put it this
way what guy would be like ew we're
pooping you can't do it now maybe he's
talking about that maybe she he thinks
that she
you know the pun intended [__] on the
occasion and I will say I will say uh if
I ask Kristen after we both went
diarrheaing she would probably be like
why did you do it then but but that
isn't again that isn't what happened she
obviously baked into the fact that she's
asking the guy and that like him as a
guy would probably think that's funny
and cute whereas I don't think that she
would probably be the same better woman
but but so you said take the gender
thing out of it though no I'm saying is
take the gender thing at face value she
was told to ask him I'm saying don't
flip it around I agree with you except
for I'm not as hard-lined I understand
what the guy's saying no I think the guy
should go to hell or at least go to jail
for the rest of his life
you should go to hell all right expedite
his his you know trip to hell and uh I
do agree with her except for also I
understand where the guy's coming from
if the maybe the guy's not being an
[__] about it maybe he's just saying
like listen uh that was really sweet and
I get the humor of it but can you do it
in a different way in a special way it
would be nice if that's the how he did
it my advice to you is to find another
guy all right all right
but if you want another way to ask him
Matt takes the commercial goes like this
every kiss begins with
um
where's the toilet paper I mean I this
is why it bothers me so much dude when
people
buy this be so much because what people
that I'm intimate with or even not ask
me to do something yeah for them that I
think is sweet or whatever and then I do
it and then the person is like no that's
not how I wanted it it's like
then don't
[__] okay [__] listen ask John
Malkovich listen I get I understand that
and I agree with it okay okay
however
this was during
explosive diarrhea I think that makes it
funny I think she's completely I think
she's a hundred percent right actually I
think it was that is funny and in its
own way that is cute in fact
like those kinds of things bind people
even closer together when they go
through it together it was [__] coming
out of your ass that makes it funny dude
not funny like I actually I gotta tell
you something I don't think it makes it
funny
I don't think that that's funny it's not
but you know what I mean it's not
offensive it's not like I just don't
think if the guy thinks it's offensive
that's one thing I just if someone were
to ask me to marry them while we were
[__] our brains out I wouldn't think
that was I would think that's funny
that's yeah that's hilarious dude it's
the most ridiculous thing to do in the
world it is because people hype it up so
much they're like plan these most epic
yeah so it's like you're [__] on the
idea of proposing which is not special I
get that no it's really special
it's really special okay well we
disagree then she's great he's an idiot
I'm not saying she's not great I'm not
saying he's not an idiot I don't know
the guy I but I am saying she's great
and that he is an idiot all right next
one yeah
what's up Chris what's up Matt
um you guys are awesome appreciate
everything you guys do thanks man
um I just need some advice from you guys
um my fiance and I are getting married
in three months and her mom
my student mother-in-law which we're
very I'm very close to
um
is
diagnosed with breast cancer and long
story short
metastasized to her brain and it looks
like she might not make the wedding so
me and her do not know what to do do we
push the wedding off
uh until everything subsides do we
try to bring like someone in to get us
married in front of her we don't know
what to do everything's
fresh and yeah so
just appreciate you guys thank you for
everything you guys do seriously that's
sweet I'm sorry bro that's rough it's
rough for your wife it's rough for you I
I answered for the mom I think my my
first thought immediately thought was do
a really small thing with her get
actually married yes and uh have her be
there or you know and a few people you
know that your your parents your
brothers whatever and then uh and then
wait and take care of her and then when
she passes you know after a little bit
then you can have like a we're married
party you know um and keep it basically
the same wedding yeah it's gonna be but
yeah because it's hard to celebrate when
you're going through this rough time man
and I get that and and and I don't think
that the mom you know sounds like you're
very close so I don't think that the mom
would want you to really not celebrate
and not you know be a burden and so or
rush it so you're kind of get getting
the best of everything if you do those
things yeah you know because it's
probably important to look I'm sure it's
important to you but it's probably
important to your wife that her mom be
there yeah of course yeah yeah
um because I'm you know the mom if she's
like any other Mom unless she's like a
monster which doesn't know she is she
she'd probably be like oh I I don't want
to mess anything up yeah of course so
you're not messing something up you you
know you want to be you look I look we
want you here we understand that you may
not be around for the next however long
and we want to do it with you there and
and and and you don't have to worry
about soiling the actual event because
there will be an event you get both
um that's and we want you to be there
yeah I think that's good yeah I I fully
agree yeah
yeah and because you can even just go to
the courthouse and just do that and have
her be there you know but I like the
idea of like an actual small ceremony at
one of your houses maybe if she can't
leave her house maybe do it there yeah I
have like 10 people it's really sweet
too it's really memorable for you guys
and well that's the other thing yeah it
sure it'll make her the end of her life
yeah at least one very beautiful moment
that was kind of like tailored for her
and that is that is beautiful and also
it's something you'll remember as Chris
said for the rest of your lives and
it'll be a fond memory of this woman
that you both really care about yeah
I think that's cool yeah and I think
that you should start setting it up
before you even tell your wife this way
it takes the burden off of her trying to
do it having to do it and it seems like
you're actively doing something and
caring and yeah I just think that it
would be really sweet and also I think
you should do it when you both have
explosive diarrhea you should tell her
what the new plan is when you're you
know explosively [__] because
everybody loves it depending on how far
along the cancer is you might be
[__] anyway you know oh okay
um uh not to be dark but yeah well it
was breast and brain maybe I should have
made that joke but well I mean it
affects everything oh wow you know no I
just won't let it go you know all right
all right next one next one is there
another one okay
hey Matt hey Chris love the show man
been a baby since like 2017.
I got these friends I met line dancing
these two girls totally platonic never
been like that anyways we became good
friends we were friends for a long time
then I got kind of busy I got a second
job I started teaching swing dance and I
got a girlfriend dude and after a while
I kind of stopped going to a few of
their things not all of them just a few
because I have work or whatever they
stopped inviting me to things wholesale
like I see them do things online they
never invite me and their excuses always
like oh we thought you'd be busy or
whatever
then I talked to them they're like well
you don't have enough upkeep you don't
text us enough like you don't talk to us
you don't invite us to the things you're
doing
I don't do anything right right like I'm
at home or at the bar where I see you
every week or you invite me to the thing
yeah so like
What's your deal with high maintenance
friendships because I feel like guys can
just not see each other for like two
years get some wings things are fine you
know help generally that's true but I've
known enough guys over my way I've known
guys in my very short lifetime I'm very
young who have been the way that you are
describing incredibly high maintenance
to the point that I've had to be like yo
I actually can't be your friend actors
are like that uh this guy was not an
actor this guy built mausoleums
so not an actor just a dude he built
Mausoleum that's the worst job in the
world you know
um I mean well actors are like that
though that doesn't take away from what
I said so hung up on the actors then uh
he was just acting like I think maker
high maintenance friends are pretty much
the worst kind of friend is what I think
I just don't understand like I they must
have like all sorts of abandonment
issues and like weird childhoods and but
we've all had [__] in our childhoods but
like that's just really odd a high
maintenance friend a high maintenance
significant other I understand yeah me
too I think I am I can be that way yeah
you know but like that's a weird [__]
thing man you have other friends also
hang with also don't if you're a friend
don't you want your friend to come and
go as they please like I I specifically
want my friends to see me as much as
they want to see me as long as I also
want to see them I don't want them to
come every single time I ask them if
they don't want to or can't or it's very
difficult I want them to do it the way
that is best for their life but I also
want to invite them so if they can come
or do want to hang do whatever the [__]
it is that's that we're talking about I
can see them and we can hang on it's
great friendships by definition have to
be low maintenance or very worst in
mid-maintenance otherwise it's honestly
not really a friendship it's like a
weird
yeah rival rivalry thing I don't
understand
you're a guy and she's a girl
it's weird
it's it's just odd dude yo are we
[__] like you know what I mean it's
like that was gonna be my question like
I I know he said it's always been
platonic but like
he said it's two girls right yeah he
said two girls is there any kind of
weird thing with either one of them that
you either liked her in the past or she
liked you and the pastor something like
that because if that's the case then it
makes a little it's not like he's not a
handsome guy yeah maybe he's gay or I
don't know we don't know you know yeah I
don't know but the yeah
um he's not stereotypically gay as you
think of gay but well maybe they're gay
you know I don't know who who is or who
isn't gay because this isn't a he didn't
get into that maybe everyone's gay you
know I think everybody's gay but um yeah
but um
I don't like yeah that's a [__] weird
thing I think you should just
they're already it seems like you're
busy if they're gonna be like that but
he also seems a certain way he feels
like a certain way about well what the
[__] I they don't invite me to things
right I think you should just say
basically what you said to us like
about the thing about well you don't
invite us to things either it's like
well I don't have things to invite you
to right right if I did of course I
would invite you you're my friends yeah
but I don't so you're it's like they're
assuming you have your own things that
you refuse to invite them to maybe
they're just under a wrong impression
and maybe it would change if they
understood oh dude I know what it is
they think you're a chick
they think you're a chick that doesn't
work with dudes just phase it out it's
working on him he's always I know but
but you have to remind yourself you're
not a chick when you hang around chicks
it's like The Joe Rogan thing thing it's
like The Joe Rogan joke where he was
like he said is Bruce does Bruce Jenner
really think that he's a woman or did he
did he just hang around too many women
long enough he became one like uh uh
that's what's happening dude so pretty
soon you're gonna be trans no that's not
what's happening could happen I think
all that is happening is that
you're friends with two really weird
people that are like yeah they've
obviously are friends with each other
because they [__] aren't that same
way is that that's like not that the way
they're being is not what being a friend
is so if you're asking about high
maintenance friends I don't know some
you keep some you don't it depends on
who you are and where you are in your
life those two people seem like bad
friends to me that's not that's not a
high maintenance thing that's like a
that's like they're transactional that's
not what a friend is yeah a friend is a
friend fair weather friend a friend is a
friend whether they ask you about a line
dancing job everything will never asks
you to do anything they're just always
the same because they're your friend and
that's they've given you their
friendship and that's that and he sees
them at the bar and the bar is where
they're line dancing is that what he's
saying I don't I missed that he said you
see him at the bar once a week or
something right Anthony yeah he did no
he said that he's asleep and then he
left he quit yeah uh no I I think that
maybe they work together yeah I don't
know I thought I might have missed I
don't know but whatever but yeah it's
okay I just stop being friends with them
that might be in your future yeah that
might be a new future
and get guy friends
you know
um okay yeah that's good
um appreciate you guys Lifeline luxury
out today go to patreon.com Lifeline
luxury and get the uh there's like six
episodes out now or something
um and then I'll be in Charlotte and
Vegas uh Charlotte North Carolina and
Little Rock Arkansas little [__]
Arkansas no it's not little car park
inside this little rock it is when
you're there
and then Knoxville which is coxville
when I'm there and um and then uh
Montreal and a bunch of different places
go to chrisley.com uh if you have a
question go to watch lifeline.com or hit
the hotline the link is in the
description below and uh you want a
one-on-one advice session with Matt go
to mattelia.com he's got great great
devices hey right now why don't you go
to the lifelinemerch.com and check out
see if you like the merch go ahead and
pick up some hot merch from Lifeline
thank you very much I would like like
And subscribe and let me know if I'm
autistic thank you very much
[Music]
hello